für mich hat sie in diesem ganzen
wahlkampf in diesen letzten wochen viel
zu viel
weltuntergang drin gehabt klima
katastrophe
pandemie panik und nazi machtergreifung
also das war eine orgie der melancholie
auf allen kanälen über mehrere wochen
die deutschen medien und die politik
tanzen den apokalypse und deshalb halte
ich hier in aller entschiedenheit
dagegen
deutschland ist viel besser als das was
die medien und die politik in diesem
wahlkampf aus deutschland gemacht hat
ich behaupte her deutschland ist ein
unterschätztes weltwunder sie sind ein
weltwunder des überlebens 1945 am boden
61 hat deutschland bruttosozialprodukt
pro kopf bereits die franzosen und die
engländer wie beruf deutschland ist ein
weltwunder der
des wohlstands sie haben ein
wirtschaftswunder hingelegt sie haben
die eu finanziert sie haben eine
wiedervereinigung gestellt und
deutschland ist auch ein weltwunder der
stabilität in der finanzkrise war
deutschland der fels in der brandung der
anke vernunft in dieser europäischen
union die außer rand und band
und deshalb glaube ich auch nicht dass
eine partei mit den drei buchstaben af
de oder eine linksextreme partei dieses
bollwerk der stabilität
deutschland irgendwie in gefahr bringen
kann dieses drama queen gezieltere kann
ich nicht nachvollziehen als ich
appelliere hier auch vor dem hintergrund
dass die deutschen ein bodenständiges
volk sind tüchtig sind augenmaß hat und
vor allem auch selbstkritisch ihr seid
ja viel selbstkritischer als die
arroganten franzosen die sorglosen
südländer oder die snobistischen briten
die seitlich ein großartiges land und wo
ist hier das deutsche selbstvertrauen
geblieben wo ist die die zuversicht
geblieben wo ist der aufbruch geblieben
ich appelliere an deutschland und ich
bitte euch seid doch auch mal ein
bisschen stolz auf euch und dreht nicht
die ganze zeit euer eigenes land durch
den fleischwolf geschlossen wer gestern
abend ja gesehen in der großen
schlussrunde die politik das war ja ein
aufbruch oder haben sie auch gesehen ich
sage es mal aufbruch stimmung pur muss
man ja sagen kann dass ich finde es
schön dass wir von dem von dem
weltwunder hören vom chefredakteur der
weltwoche das passt natürlich ganz
hervorragend das aber ist schön so etwas
zu hören quasi aus dem nicht dass er
nicht so fernen schweiz dass wir auch
mal ein bisschen lob bekommen als
deutsche sage ich quasi als immigrations
kind auch gerne insofern wunderbares ihr
körper das ist wirklich toll aber sie
kommen ja auch mal gerne gluckst immer
gerne auch auf die fakten die sind ja so
dass wir sehen ein abschmelzen dieser
großen volksparteien eine entwicklung
die wir in europa sehen die eigentlich
überall
vorangegangen ist in italien in
frankreich die am große sorgen machen
kann auch die vielleicht so eine
normalität wird einer neuen und wir
leben müssen mit dreier bündnissen in
anderen ländern gibt siebener bündnissen
in den niederlanden ist man auch keine
mehrheit zustande gekommen also da
können wir auf instabile verhältnisse
vielleicht kommen in den nächsten
jahrzehnten wir wissen es nicht und ein
zweites natürlich wissen die deutschen
dass sie was tun und leisten können und
das wollen sie auch alle aber sie wissen
auch dass in den nächsten zehn jahren
kein stein auf dem anderen bleibt das
ist bei der e-mobilität
wahnsinnige veränderung geht ein punkt
den du ja immer auch erwähnt dass es bei
den bei den ganzen energiefragen groß
veränderungen geht in der arbeitswelt
massive veränderung und da wollen sie
natürlich stabile verhältnisse haben die
ein auch dadurch will die deutschen sind
klüger und tüchtiger und besser als ihre
politiker das ist nur mal die erste
feststellung die wir ihn einfach mal
reifen müssen und das zweite weißt du
was mich ganz besonders zuversichtlich
macht die deutschen sind auch
weltmeister darin die probleme zu
überwinden wie sie sich selber
eingebrockt haben da habe ich einen
riesigen respekt vor der
problemlösungsfähigkeit der deutschen
also ich bleibe zuversichtlich ich setze
hier ein bäumchen der hoffnung in
unserer sendung ich finde das gut dass
die optimistischen ich bin als junger
mensch auch einfach per sich auf die
wissenschaft die zukunft eigentlich
immer besser ist als ihr ruf aber
gleichzeitig dieses was sie so ein
bisschen der nörgelnde deutsche der zu
viel weil seine eigenen probleme rede
demografie haben sie ja zum beispiel
noch vergessene sicherungssysteme wie
erwirtschaften überhaupt wohlstand wenn
alle denen nur verteilen wollen ist ja
eigentlich fast positives weil ich
glaube dass ist die eigenschaft wie wir
dann die großen herausforderungen auch
überhaupt erstmal ist ein
original eingeschlossen
problembewusstsein hat nur eine gute
problemanalyse und corona hat die
probleme das staatswesen doch offen
gelegt also wenn wir von bürokratie bis
faxgeräte nachverfolgen
gesundheitsämtern rädern dann gibt's
schon ganz schön modernisierungsbedarf
in diesem land auch wenn wir historisch
viel erreicht haben aber es ist ein
positiver appell dass man schaffen kann
das zeigt die vergangenheit aber muss es
auch tun und in den letzten jahren
hatten wir schon an der ein oder andere
stelle da habe ich zu viel stillstand
auch politisch und der schweizer hat
hier auch gut reden sie lachen selbst
weil natürlich die schweiz ein magnet
ist für sehr erfolgreiche leute hängt
unter anderem mit dem steuersystem
zusammen das kann man jetzt in
deutschland nicht unbedingt behaupten
wenn man sich mal anschaut wer
eigentlich die großen erfindungen also
die technologie die digitalisierung
vorangetrieben hat und wo diese meistens
sind es männer leider gottes muss man
sagen sind zu wenig frauen dabei wird
die eigentlich wohnen denn wohnen die
vorwiegend in den usa und da wohnen auch
die neuen milliardäre china lasse ich
jetzt mal raus die wohl nicht in
deutschland werde die großen erfindungen
der letzten 20 jahre kommen nicht aus
diesem land die kommen aus anderen
ländern möglicherweise gehen danach
einige dieser erfinden die schweiz seien
aber ich habe auch immer aus hier und
genau wie oder lag es hatte sap wir sind
dann auch schon ziemlich schnell wenn
wir aufzählen wo die großen digital
riesen eigentlich sitzen und sie müssen
lachen weil sie wahrscheinlich auch
selbst in heidenheim ich muss noch mal
drüber nach hin wo es noch ganz schön
würde mich lachen muss sagen sie ich
habe ich noch gedacht dass mir diese
rhetorisch beschlagen den deutschen
meinen optimismus ausreden wenn ich sage
nicht bestreiten wenn man sich das ist
zuhause
sitzen ganz ganz kleines beispiel weil
sich heute denn deine oder gelesen habe
deutschland das unterschätzte merkt man
da habe ich mich gefreut rutsche ich
habe mich gefreut und dachte endlich
sagt es mal endlich weihnachten meisten
trainer hast du glaub ich meinen twitter
oder gesagt hat man das gefühl man muss
sich betrinken so schlimm steht es um
unser land das waren wir sehr fassen
analyse es gibt ein beispiel was mich
immer nervt ist jetzt ein ganz kleines
optisch auf die deutschen übertreiben in
jedem wahlkampf wird jeder gesagt
whiteboards die schüler haben noch tafel
villingen so weit zurück die haare
business school worauf schreibt die
harvard business school auf tafeln so
ist hat auch sozialistische gründe wir
brauchen gute lehrer aber wenn der
lehrer hervorragendes brauchen wir nicht
in jeder deutschen schule ein whiteboard
und es braucht auch nicht außerhalb von
rom ohne jedes kind schon in der ersten
klasse einen laptop und der ist zum
beispiel so ein problem wo ich sage also
darüber bedauernd geredet man hat das
gefühl wenn man robert zuhörer
whiteboards werden unsere schüler
überall hin treiben und das ist ein
problem wo ich sage wir haben doch auch
ein gutes education system unser
ausbildungssystem ist das beste der welt
bin dagegen dass wir wirklich will ich
persönlich lange nicht so sicher ja
lange nicht mehr solche rechnungen
schenkt sich zeigt hier hat und die in
berlin hat der lwl haben natürlich
jahres ist die hauptstadt ich glaube
nicht dass wir der unterschätztes
unterschätzte weltwunder sicher wir sind
der satte champion und beim punkt
bildung geht es richtig los also wenn
ich jetzt sehe dass sechsklässler
beispielsweise in dieser rot rot grün
regierten stadt gar keine aufsätze mehr
schreiben sechsklässler lernen aber
jetzt präsentation anzufertigen können
auch nicht wenig schreiben ja aber
lernen jetzt schon wie man eine
präsentation
aber das ist es wichtig dass wir in der
sechsten klasse in der sechsten klasse
muss ich lernen wie ich richtig schreibe
ich kann dann wenn ich richtig schreiben
kann anfangen die nächsten schritt zu
machen und eine braucht innovation hier
das
aber ist das land getan tools richtig
schreiben so bedeutend weil laut
paradisi.de erfolg schmecken aber es ist
ihnen aber ich will einmal kam was
schlecht ist nicht gesagt dass die
großen sechs wieder groß ja wissen wie
man ein bisschen rechtschreibung dann
aber auch wieder nach dem
arbeitsschwerpunkt in eine präsentation
das sind natürlich skills die immer
wichtiger werden weißt du wie lange der
nil ist wann in napoleon auf elba war
eine berühmte beispiele zu sagen einmal
das kannst du alles googeln vielleicht
brauchst du natürlich um zusammenhänge
zu wissen geschichte ein ort und ganz
klar aber
präsentationen das credo der
journalisten schreiben kann der das denn
neben dem cut ist der sechsten klasse
kannst du schon die rechtschreibung
hoffentlich
auch positiv zusammenfassend sagte
beeindruckend einige eindrücke der band
verbrecher eindruck und ist ist die
selbstkritik und da haben sie recht mit
dieser selbstkritik werdet ihr alle
probleme löst
[Musik]